diese schwulen pinguine das fand ich
eher nicht nur weil ich selber ein
schwuler pinguin bin sondern heute
sprechen wir über eine graphic novel von
lift strömt wisst sie ist gehen ja was
soll da eine sehr interessante seite
aufgeschlagen zeigt das doch mal so groß
sei auch dass deine lieblings seite das
hier zb fand ich auch nicht schlecht da
ist ja homer simpson eigentlich der
übergewichtige biertrinken der glatzkopf
es werden einfach die stereo tourführer
quasi umgekehrt es geht hier in diesem
buch sehr viel um beziehungen auch und
es ist ja meist dargestellt an sehr
berühmten künstlern wie john lennon
elvis presley pablo picasso karl marx
die geschichte von priscilla presley zum
beispiel ist schon auch ein bisschen wie
soll ich an einseitig die geschichten
wurden immer über den mann erzählt und
jetzt werden sie einfach mal über die
frau erzählt da kann man sagen es ist
einseitig aber bei einem mann habe ich
nie gesagt dass aber einseitig wo es
eigentlich für sich schon ich hatte da
auch schon kritische anmerkung ich finde
ja diese stellen des buches die weniger
guten weil künstler ehen oder künstler
beziehungen sind immer komplex ich finde
das buch wird da interessant wo es sich
genau über diese grenzen die es in
diesem fall dann selber zieht
hinwegsetzt zb diese schwulen pinguine
ja das fand ich nicht nur weil ich
selber ein schwuler pinguinen bin
sondern weil die idee die dahinter steht
folgende ist wir schauen in die natur
und sagen wenn etwas natürlich ist dann
ist das gut das wird ja hier mit recht
sehr kritisiert in der philosophie nennt
man das naturalistischer fehlschluss
wenn es in der natur-schule pinguine
gibt dann ist es auch beim menschen ok
und sie sagt es gibt ja auch keine otter
die tabletten nehmen oder keine tiere
die in den ikea-katalog schauen ja genau
ich gerade an führen aber dann hast du
mich unterbrochen bitten den dreh ist
dass sie sagt und es gibt ganz viele
tiere in der natur die ein furchtbares
verhalten leben und deren verhalten sich
der mensch auch nicht geeignet unter der
rubrik es ist doch natürlich zum
beispiel die herzog ich brauche
unbedingt text sagt ihr eine frau zur
anderen ich gehe einfach jetzt raus auf
die straße und lasse mich von les murs
besten mann besprechen und dann sagt die
antwort das ist völlig natürlich
das machen katzen genauso und darf ich
dich zum abschluss fragen ob du mir
zustimmen würde ist ich fürchte nicht
aber ich versuche trotzdem das
vielleicht dieser geschlechter
blickpunkt nicht immer zielführend ist
[Musik]